hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
socially distanced experiments the
importance of single lab accessible
automation in driving high quality
proteomics research
i am jennifer woods of labruz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by biotechne
to learn more visit biotechne.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
chris haeger
director of application science
analytical solutions division of
biotechne
dr hager you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for that introduction my name
is chris hager director of application
science for the analytical solutions
division of biotechne
i'm here today to talk about socially
distance experiments and
the importance of single lab accessible
automation
in driving high quality proteomics
research
in our lab we have employed the
following strategies over the past year
to keep people safe
we started with the reduced workforce on
site to enable social distancing with
remote work and staggered on-site hours
we washed our hands a lot
we wore and continued to wear masks in
accordance with local state and federal
guidance
and lastly we were able to minimize the
actual time spent in the lab
and moved data retrieval and analysis to
the home office
we're all familiar with the first three
strategies here but it's the last one
that i
want to dive into more today
biotechny is a diverse supportive
organization with several brands to
support your research needs
including acd novus tocrus
r d systems and as the focus will be
today
protein simple
together these brands provide a broad
portfolio of tools for research
including cytokines growth factors and
small molecules
media and supplements most of these are
offered at gmp grade as well as research
grade
we also have world-class immunoassays
and ish technology
and a wide variety of proteins and
antibodies
in addition protein simple provides
analytical instrumentation
our goal is to offer all these
innovative solutions with flexibility
and customization to fit your needs
with the consistency reproducibility and
scalability you require
today i'm here to discuss one of our
protein simple platforms
simple western in more detail
analytical tools are constantly evolving
to adapt to the rapidly changing
research and development landscape
sometimes these changes are geared
towards allowing the researcher to make
faster insights
as is generally the case with using
today's smartphone compared to a desktop
computer
from 20 years ago sometimes these
changes are meant to help provide a
better view
has been is the case for the microscope
as it's evolved
when i think about protein simple and
simple western
in the context of these pictures i'm
pretty confident
placing this logo alongside these images
the traditional western blot has been
around for 40 years
and while being a key research tool
still persists in a form that looks
pretty similar to what was available for
years ago there have certainly been
innovations to help improve the overall
process
but it is still just that a process it's
a process that requires a lot of gear
and a lot of time
up to 48 hours in some instances and
yields results that really aren't worth
the effort
the simple western platform on the other
hand takes the entire process
innovates and automates it all in one
box
completed start to finish in as little
as three hours
having personally run thousands of plots
the old way i truly wish
this platform had been around when i was
running traditional westerns
the simple western platform is the new
gold standard in western blotting
it's our completely automated
capillary-based western block platform
that removes the laborious
notorious western blot from your
workflow giving you back time and
confidence in your data
with high precision and reproducibility
the simple western platform features
fast time to results
the platforms offer fully automated size
and charge amino assays
capable of completing a run in as little
as three hours
the simple western platform offers
quantitative data either
absolute or relative protein
quantitation
with our fantastic compass for simple
western software which we'll talk about
more today
the simple western platform has high
throughput capabilities
as well as flexibility up to 96 samples
can be
run in a single run on our high
throughput instruments
we have a wide variety of multiplexing
capabilities across the platforms
and several different platforms to
choose from to best fit your needs
all of our simple western platform
instruments
offer outstanding reproducibility with
low inter and
trial assay cvs
and lastly really important for those
folks working with precious samples
is low sample volume the simple western
platform
uses less than three microliters per
well
you can get exquisite sensitivity of
microgram level
the simple western immunoassay takes
place in a capillary
your sample primary and secondary
antibodies as well as the separation and
running buffers are loaded automatically
from a specifically designed plate
just starts by aspirating the separation
matrix
this is followed by aspiration of the
stacking matrix into each capillary
next your protein sample is loaded
and then the capillaries are lowered to
make contact with running buffer
voltage is applied to separate proteins
by their apparent molecular weight
once separation is complete uv light
immobilizes the proteins of the
capillary wall
and with the proteins immobilized and
separation materials cleared from the
capillaries
jeff starts the immunoprobing process
samples are first incubated with primary
antibody
and then in the case of
chemiluminescence an hrp
conjugated secondary antibody and
finally
the chemiluminescent substrate the
chemiluminescent substrate reacts
and is recorded by a ccd camera and a
series of images over time
now that i've introduced the technology
a little it's time to introduce the
simple western family
members we have three small footprint
instruments
wes jess and abby that can run simple
western size assays in as little as
three hours
they all have ultra sensitive
chemiluminescence and jess has dual
color fluorescence as well
and you can replex on both jess and abby
we also have three larger throughput
instruments sally sue peggy sue and the
nanopro 1000
these instruments can process up to 96
capillaries per run
and can run size ief or both
depending on the model all three of
these larger instruments have ultra
sensitive chemoluminescence detection
as well
since simple western is an automated
platform the reproducibility is
outstanding
whether you're looking within a run like
this pi3 kinase cdk6 multiplex
where we have cvs for 24 replicates
under 10
for each target or day-to-day
and user-to-user like here on the right
where we have four different users
running experiments on four different
days for one
pretty good week of data with cvs under
12 per day
and overall under 10 for four days with
44 replicas
simple western has multiple detection
capabilities
the technology was founded with ultra
sensitive chemiluminescence at its core
here's a great example where we can
detect as little as 0.4 nanograms per
mil
of cd19 a car t therapy target
but simple western has also evolved over
the years and now includes two color
fluorescents as well
here's a beautiful example looking at
egfr signaling
the pond stimulation with egf the egf
receptor switches on
by virtue of dimerization and
phosphorylation
we can monitor that with a
phospho-specific egfr antibody
in a431 cells in the absence of
stimulation
the egfr receptor is not phosphorylated
as is shown in lane 1.
but there is plenty of egfr in these
cells as illustrated in lane two
with a total egfr antibody
however upon stimulation with egf in
lane four
we see a large increase in the
phosphoegfr detected
as well as in lane 6 which is a
multiplex of total and fossil egfr
both ultra-sensitive chemiluminescence
and our dual-color fluorescence are
compatible with our reflex feature
let's quickly define reflex reflex is
defined as two rounds of immunoprobe and
detection
in a single capillary this assay
leverages the unique
covalent immobilization chemistry at the
heart of the simple western technology
and is compatible with the
chemiluminescence fluorescence and total
protein assays
importantly since you're getting a
second data point from the same
capillary and same sample using replex
reduces the cost per data point too
so in our normal workflow where we first
separated sample and immobilize it
the reflex takes place after the first
detection
an example output will be shown here
where
the two different lanes are for the
actual different probes that happen
in the same exact capillary so in probe
one for this capillary we looked at a
multiplex of hsp60 and gap ch
and then upon reflexing the same exact
capillary was interrogated
for a multiplex of 1433 and park seven
let's take a quick look at a reflex
example
here's an example of how we leveraged
replex for breast cancer research a
field that is near and dear to me
here we are looking at akt signaling in
mcf7 breast cancer cells in response to
stimulation with igf-1
for this experiment we use the
pan-aktn's body
detected with mir secondary shown in red
here
and two different phospho-akt antibodies
to either phosphoserine 473
or phospho3 meaning 308 detected with
hrp secondary for chemiluminescence
detection
shown in black upon stimulation with
igf-1
significant increases in akt
phosphorylation
at both phosphosites is observed
in this assay we use the replex to go
back over the same capillaries and
interrogate them for the total protein
loaded in probe 2 shown on the bottom in
blue for these samples
using the data obtained in replex we can
correct our immunoassay data with that
total protein
information which is automatically done
by the compass software
and that's shown by the area column
which is before correction
and the corrected area which takes into
account the total protein
data
i wanted to spend a few minutes talking
about peggy sue and what she brings to
the table for size separations
our higher throughput instruments
including pegisu
shown here can really help you get the
most out of a precious sample
let's walk through a quick example so i
can show you what i mean
let's imagine that these are eight
sample wells
let's put two patient samples sample one
and sample two in those wells
where we are looking at whole cell and
nuclear extracts
of either basal or tnf alpha treated
cells
placing only five microliters of sample
per well
those samples will be interrogated for
eight different targets in this run
for the nf kappa b pathway so whereas
five microliters
might get you a single well on a
traditional western for this assay
here we're getting eight times more data
the instrument is able to process
capillaries in groups that we call
cycles and when this run is completed
peggy sue has elucidated an entire
pathway the nf kappa b
pathway in this example and the loading
control
for these samples so if you look down in
an entire column
these are all individual data points
from unique
capillaries on a peggy sue for
individual targets
so a lot of data coming out of a single
run
on a pegisu from single wells of sample
in addition to the size separation
capabilities i've described
we also offer charge separation of
proteins on peggy sue and the nano pro
1000
in this separation mode we use the same
capillary capture
and in capillary immunoassay approach
but leverage the isoelectric point of
the target protein
this allows one to look at subtle
changes in a protein that cannot be
detected by size separation
like for example phosphorylation which
only adds 80 daltons to the protein
with charge separation each
phosphorylation acidifies the protein
moving it to the left of this pi scale
let's look at an example of the map
kinase proteins erc-1 and earth-2
these proteins require dual
phosphorylation to become active kinases
using a single antibody that detects
both erc1 and nerve2
when the heliolysate is separated by
charge we see two main peaks
one for each earth protein
when we look at heal cells that have
been stimulated with egf
we see a rapid increase in two acidic
species
at pis 5.2 and 5.8 which are the
diphospho
species of erc1 and nerve 2. we also see
concordant decrease in the non-phosphate
forms
additionally there's a small amount of
change in the monophosphor work one
species
these changes can be quantified and
after egf treatment
the two erc proteins are nearly 90
phosphorylated
the same assay approach is used by
researchers to look at
lung cancer and emphysema
in the top panel are irk signatures from
normal lung tissue shown in blue
and from lung cancer tumors shown in red
there's essentially no visible
difference between them and we see
predominantly irk one and nerve two
however in the bottom panel where normal
lung tissue is compared to lung tissue
from emphysema patients
there's a stark difference we see that
this assay might be useful to help
better understand this disease
these observations are quantifiable and
the data were shown to be statistically
significant
the charge assay has been used in many
other ways to look at other
post-translational modifications
or in instances where proteins cannot be
separated
by their size
simple western has been supporting
researchers for nearly 10 years
and today i can happily show you that
the simple western
has been used to help publish over 1 000
peer-reviewed publications
and is on quite an upward trajectory at
this point
this table on the left does not include
patents and doctoral thesis work either
so the number is
is actually a little bit higher than
what i'm showing here
these publications are featured in
diverse research areas as shown on the
right
everything from cell biology to clinical
research vaccine development
and bioprocessing and these publications
are in top-notch journals with simple
western data gracing the pages of
science
cell and nature journals
let's now talk a little bit more about
how simple western can help maximize
your social
distance time a little bit more detail
about its
fast setup time fast time to results
about how we have remote data access
available
a little bit more about our powerful
all-in-one easy to use software
i'm even going to provide some examples
from the past year
about how we at protein simple have
stayed successful
while socially distancing using the
simple western instruments
simple western assays on west jess and
abby take as little as 30 minutes to set
up
importantly to maximize social
distancing we have the run file saved to
a network or share folder before we
leave the lab
or the site
setting up the assay is easy and that's
partly because everything you need to
run simple western is neatly organized
and accounted for
in our separation and detection modules
these high quality reagents all undergo
rigorous quality control
to help ensure your data is the best it
can be every time
we also offer a la carte options if you
need a little bit more of something
specific
i showed you what happens once the
consumables are inside the instrument
but let's review the
sample run prep workflow first you
prepare your samples
pretty much the same way as you would
for traditional western
you'll add a master mix to help denature
the samples in the presence of sds
often with reducing agent and a little
bit of heat
and then the samples along with primary
and secondary antibodies
are aspirated and dispensed into the
specific simple western plate shown here
on the right
after everything's loaded into the plate
the plate and the capillaries get loaded
into the instrument
then you hit start and walk away
as we hit start in the compass software
which controls the simple western
instrument
we can set up remote data access for
simple western as well
last summer we put together this remote
tools protocol to help our simple
western customers
get their data while off-site it's
actually really straightforward
in the compass run start menu the
software will ask you where you want to
save the data
at this point you need to point the save
path to a shared folder
that has network access
for more information on how to set up a
networked folder simply google it after
hitting start
wes jess and abby go to work and
complete the run in as little as three
hours with only 30 minutes of hands-on
time
these assays are the best and most
efficient westerns available
so we go home and after three hours the
data is written to the network folder
which we now have access to remotely
compass software is free and available
for personal computer use as well
and the same software is used to design
assays
monitor the instrument and analyze
data so after you have your data in hand
you can analyze it
as well as plan your next experiment
before returning to site
and while you're waiting for your run to
complete we have an additional feature
for you
that's right you can keep an eye on your
run while you're away with twitter
let's take a quick look at how to set
that up
okay inside the compass software
preferences there's a tab for twitter
after clicking on that section we can
now see various options
the first thing to do is allow compass
access to twitter
you'll be asked to add a username and a
password and then to authenticate the
login
afterwards we'll head back to the
compass preferences and send a test
tweet
to make sure your instrument is sending
out messages
after confirming the test tweet your
instrument is ready to tell you how it's
doing
and when it's done let's take a quick
check in on an instrument's twitter page
here's a screen grab from a just
instrument's twitter page
this chess is just getting started so
there's only a few test tweets
but this is the interface you can get
tweets from your instrument when the run
is started or completed
or get a tweet if any errors pop up
during the run
although that's pretty rare tweet to get
we've accomplished a lot this year with
these strategies and our instruments
in march 2020 our development team
mobilized to develop a serology module
for sars cov2
this module features five recombinant
sars cov2 antigens
that can be used to probe for individual
reactivities from serum antibodies
to various parts of the virus thereby
affording a deeper understanding of the
infection
to test the reactivity of serum samples
against these antigens we analyzed serum
samples that were confirmed positive for
cova 19 by pcr
in this analysis serum samples are used
as the primary antibody
and the secondary anti-human igg hrp
conjugate
supplied in the module was used for
chemiluminescence detection
two pcr negative serum samples were
included as negative controls
this analysis showed a high degree of
reactivity of the pcr-positive serum
samples with the antigens included in
the kit
as expected there was little to no
reactivity
occurred with the pcr negative serum
samples
when the relative peak areas were
quantified this analysis revealed a high
degree of variability in igg reactivity
with each of the five antigens among the
human serum samples
for example pcr-positive sample four had
high reactivity
with the nucleocapsid protein while pcr
samples one
2 and 3 had significantly lower
reactivity with the nuclear capsid
but had increased reactivity with the
spike protein
this is critical information as it was
shown that detection of the nuclear
capsid is sensitive to early infection
while antibodies that target epitopes on
the spike protein may
be linked to neutralization overall
these data provided a much deeper
characterization of the humoral response
to cova-19
than is possible with single antigen
elisa kits
we also were able to develop several
other assays and applications in diverse
research areas
including sars coe2 biology where we
looked at ace2
and tempers2
in protac degradation of neo-substrates
and lastly in the impurity analysis of
aavs
here's a closer look at one of those
application notes where we leverage
replex
to monitor impurity analysis and aav
process samples
aavs are a promising gene therapy
delivery tool
and as such are high focus among
biotherapeutic
manufacturers
we used an anti-aav vp1 vp2 vp3 antibody
and chemiluminescence detection
followed by reflex with total protein on
these aav
in process samples for serotypes 1 4 7
and 9.
the assay only required 50 000 copies of
aav
sample per well which is great
considering how challenging it can be
to get enough aav samples to work with
and as expected the antibody reacted
quite well with aav7 and 9
but not with aav serotypes 1 or 4.
the data can easily be quantified for
both viral proteins
shown on the top or the total protein
shown on the bottom
and as i've described previously using
the total protein we can normalize
for the viral proteins within these
samples
and account for any differences in the
loading
so i've mentioned that we've done quite
a bit of work in the last year and we
did a lot of it remotely
and part of that work is making figures
we rely on our compass for simple
western software
a lot and today i wanted to show you a
quick example of how the newest version
compass 6.0 is ideal for making high
quality
publication ready figures
for this discussion we're going to use a
multiplex
assay that i actually described a little
bit earlier
but here's the entire assay so this is a
just run looking again
at those mcf7 cells in the absence or
presence of stimulation with igf-1
and we're probing with different
multiplexes for akt
signaling either phospho antibodies
with total pan akt
for either specific phosphocytes for the
isoforms
or for non-phospho-akt1 and akt2
okay so there's six different
multiplexes here
and all of these data are going to be
replexed
for total protein let's take a look at
how the run
shakes out
from this one run there are actually
three complete sets of data
because it's a multiplex in the
immunoassay
we have pan akt detected in nir shown in
the top picture
and in our chemiluminescence detection
we use either phospho-akt or
akt isoform specific antibodies
and again in the reflex we have the
total protein which is shown on the
right
so it's a lot of data let's see how we
can make that into a nice figure
with compass 6.0 making the publication
quality figures
inside of compass is really easy we have
a new lane
annotation feature shown here on the
left
upon selecting the annotations tab the
software is going to ask you to
generate a crop region after generating
a crop region
shown on the right the software allows
you a number of different options
including lane labels band labels
figure titles figure notes and other
settings taking those same data that we
started off with
i've made three different crop regions
one for each of the detection
channels but for the same capillaries
shown here is the result of that image
analysis on the right
so i've added a title indicating what
the experiment was about
as well as changed the angle of my
labels
and annotated the individual peak names
as well i have time to show you
how i did all that today we have a lot
of great help in our compass for simple
western
users guide
the biotechny academy is our online
training center
that provides all of the training
support needed to get started
after self installation of a wes jess or
abby
simply start your designated instrument
learning plan
shown here is an example of a just
instrument learning plan
the academy not only teaches you but it
also connects you with your local field
application
scientists rest assured that every user
at your site
can visit the academy at any time from
anywhere
not only does the biotechnic academy
provide a breadth of training content to
get you up and running on a variety of
instruments and platforms
but it also serves as a great resource
to continue to get a great scientific
content
to keep our customers growing as
scientists as well
in summary simple western maximizes your
social distancing strategies by virtue
of its fast prep time
and fast time to results and the ability
to set up remote run data access
since most simple western instruments
are plug-and-play once you have yours
delivered you can install it when you're
ready
essentially just by plugging it in
once you're ready to play we've got
fantastic biotechny academy for online
training
and lastly as i showed today our newest
version of compass compass 6.0
supercharges data analysis with powerful
figure annotations
that can be made anywhere anytime
without being connected
to any instrument
for more information visit us at
proteinsimple.com
and with that i'm happy to take some
questions
thank you
thank you dr hager for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first
question are there any limitations in
reviewing the data remotely
yeah hi thanks for the question and um
as i mentioned our compass software is
available for
it's free for anybody to download and
use on a personal computer
so you know one of the main limitations
with some software packages is you gotta
have a specific license for it and we
definitely don't have that in front of
you
i could imagine some related to you know
firewalls
on sites where you work that might be of
some challenge and i would recommend you
engage your i.t
department as well as reach out to our
tech support to help you
great thank you dr hager our next
question is that
what is the cost for consumables or or
does the biotechne academy cost money
so the biotechnic academy which i which
i described at the end there that
that is um a free academy as well so
any any user can sign up so if you have
five ten people in your lab they're all
able to
uh get into the academy in terms of
consumables
um i like to to tell folks that
i'm a scientist and i don't have all
those numbers at the top of my mind what
i do like to remember
is the the cost is comparable to that of
a traditional western if you if you boil
it down to the
for the nuts and bolts of it the main
difference is how much
hands-on time you know the fte time of a
traditional western that's
a lot of expense that you don't run into
with simple western
great thank you dr hager and our next
question is
what is the volume inside the capillary
yeah these are these are pretty small
capillaries i didn't describe that
they're
they're five centimeters long 100 micron
internal diameter which works out to
roughly
400 nanoliters of total internal volume
in the capillary
for the size assay that i described we'd
load a small sample plug which is
approximately 40 to 50 nanoliters
all right great we have another question
coming in
you showed some nice data for reflex but
mainly showed using total protein in the
second probe
can i use reflex with a second
immunoassay
yeah it's a good question there are a
number of different approaches or
assay combos you can use with reflex and
those include
obviously as i showed a lot of today the
immunoassay
followed by a reflexive total protein
but you can do two sequential
immunoassays
uh that those could be combinations of
our nir
and ir and chemi or you know any
combination they're in
great thanks again uh dr hager our next
question is
which instruments are compatible with
reflex
yeah so the reflex feature was launched
i believe a little bit over a year and a
half ago and it's available
on our guest instrument as well as our
newest simple western family member
abby
all right perfect thank you next
question
is the sars kobe 2 module available for
all simple western instruments
absolutely the the core components of
that kit work with
the little boxes as i like to call them
wes jess and abby as well as our higher
throughput
size based separation instruments either
the sally sue or the pegisu
great i love those names by the way
um next question have you compared the
sars kobe 2 module to an eliza
yeah that's yeah that's a question that
comes up quite a bit you know eliza is
obviously a gold standard especially in
serology assays um and we did we did do
that comparison
and it turned out really well we
compared the cantaro
eliza which is a biotechnic
collaborative effort
um and we we produced that kid and we
ran a series of samples and ran a
comparative analysis after the facts
with simple western and found
a really high percentage of agreement
for positives and
an extremely high positive agreement for
the negatives as well
demonstrating that the simple western
assay sees essentially the same thing as
the elisa but
also provides the additional information
of those other
sars kobe 2 at the gym
all right great thank you again dr hager
our next question is
you showed some nice aav work which
antibody did you use for the vp
detection
yeah thanks the dave work is something
we've been
uh we're quite proud of the what i
showed today is from our most recent
application note which i encourage
people to go check out
um the antibody we're currently using is
from a company called progen it's a
vp123 antibody
it works pretty well as i as i showed a
nice example of today
and it looks like we have time for one
last question can i use compass 6.0
on older data to make new figures
yeah that was a big one that even folks
within my own team uh were asking you
know the the ability of compass
6.0 to take out a bunch of the steps
that you typically would do in
powerpoint
um it was really powerful and and
absolutely so if it's an older wes
or just file you know pre-compass 6.0
it'll
they'll certainly be usable in compass
6.0 to make those fancy figures that i
showed
well thank you again dr hager for your
time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank labruts and
our sponsor biotechne for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye